STEPHANIE WONG: Hi.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, and today, we're
going to explore how
BigQuery, Google Cloud's fully
managed enterprise
data warehouse,
enables you to run analytics
at scale, using standard SQL
with zero operational overhead.
It provides unique
functionality,
like realtime stream
ingestion, query federation,
GIS functions, and built-in
machine learning capabilities.
And to bring this
to life, let's look
at how New Kicks,
a fictional brick
and mortar and online retailer,
uses advanced analytics
and BigQuery to optimize
their supply chain.
The challenge started when
the director of marketing
wanted to make better
ad targeting decisions.
The task was given to the
lead data scientist and data
engineer, and they recognized
four challenges to overcome.
First up was to break down
the various data silos
within their organization.
The data engineer at New Kicks
built out a one-to-end mapping
of key data sources, including
Google Analytics, raw click
stream, online transactional,
and in-store inventory data
that all move data
into BigQuery.
Store operations data is stored
in the transactional database,
Cloud SQL.
These data sources were
ingested via combination
of BigQuery data transfer
service and Cloud Dataflow
in batch and streaming mode.
Let's take a look
at this in action.
This is the Cloud
Dataflow console
showing New Kicks' real-time
ETL for in-store transactions,
stock levels, and
click stream data.
This job ran tandem with
batch and data transfer jobs
to hydrate various data
sets in the data warehouse.
The click stream step was
processing around 200 events
per second, with BigQuery
as a target output.
This data was immediately
available for querying.
For example, this query shows
the most recent click stream
events.
Note the latest event is about
two seconds behind current UTC
time.
With real-time access
to multiple data sets,
they could perform more
meaningful analysis,
like this query joining online
sales with in-store sales data,
calculating ranks for
the top 10 sneakers.
Accessibility across
various warehouses
makes the data more actionable.
However, after reviewing current
schemas in the data warehouse,
the data scientist
and data engineer
realized they needed to perform
some additional and possibly
heavy transformation and
enrichment, in order to get
the right data sets in place.
And they were going to need
some additional processing
resources to get the job done.
Now, to drive key data warehouse
workloads like ingestion, ETL,
and business
intelligence, New Kicks
used a combination of
BigQuery pricing models--
on-demand and flat rate-- to
optimize resources and cost.
For lower query volume
workloads like query prototyping
and exploratory
analysis, the IT manager
utilized on-demand pricing with
project-level cost controls.
However, the forecasting project
presented new challenges,
like unknown query
volume with the need
to minimize disruption to
existing production workloads.
In addition, resources were
only needed for a few days.
This is where the power
and value of flex slots
came into play.
Flex slots let you
purchase BigQuery capacity
for short durations-- as
little as 60 seconds at a time.
Using the BigQuery UI
or the client libraries,
the IT manager was able to
immediately allocate 500 flex
slots to a new project that
the data scientists and data
engineer could work in.
The serverless
nature of BigQuery
enables deploying this
additional capacity
in a few seconds, and can be
shut down after 60 seconds,
so it's an excellent solution
for short-term and bursty
workloads.
With their additional and
isolated capacity in place,
the team started to make
quick work on transformation
and enrichment.
To drive the forecasting
model, the team
needed to produce a filtered
and enriched click stream that
had several key
attributes, including
customer location, specific
target action, and store
location.
This required a series
of transformations,
including filtering,
joining, and applying
GIS functions, all of
which can be accomplished
at scale in BigQuery.
To perform these
transformations,
New Kicks' data
scientists executed
a series of query jobs inside
of AI platform, Notebooks,
with streamlined
integration with BigQuery.
The goal here was to
produce a filtered click
stream that was joined to
customer and in-store pickup
data.
The first query job
filtered out clicks
that meet a specific
requirement, including
active sessions that
ended with a purchase,
and an in-store pickup.
This query reduces the
analysis set from 10 terabytes
to 1 terabyte.
Notice that the
results were saved back
as a new destination table.
Next, the customer
table was enriched
with geocoordinates,
which were joined back
to the click stream.
She then joined click
stream to orders.
To obtain the geo
information for a store,
she used an external
query function
to execute a query into
the store operations
database, located on Cloud SQL.
This type of query federation
reduces data copying.
With geo information for
customers and stores,
she applied one final
transformation and filter.
Using built-in
GIS functions, she
could calculate the distance
between customer residence
and store location.
Built-in GIS
functions enable you
to project analysis
in-line without having
to export your data.
This query produces candidate
feature inputs for the model.
If she wants to
audit this process,
she can walk back through
the tables created.
Over time, these queries could
become materialized views
and/or stream or
batch transforms,
setting the foundation
for a feature store.
With the transformed
data in place,
they were able to
move onto modeling,
so they turned to BigQuery ML.
If you have experience
with machine learning,
you know that
traditional workflows
require additional
pre-processing, data splitting,
model development,
and deployment steps.
But with BigQuery ML,
steps like pre-processing,
model development, and
deployment are removed.
It lets you build
machine learning models
using standard SQL,
and without the need
to move your data for external
training and evaluation.
First, New Kicks' data
scientist and a quick sample
of the transformed
click stream data.
For this model, she wanted to
look at top line, all products,
per day, click stream
volume, so they needed
to apply a quick
transformation to group
all of the clicks by day.
No problem.
With BigQuery ML,
the data scientists
can create various model
types, including regression,
clustering, and XGBoost.
In this case, she
used ARIMA, which
is built to forecast future
time series-based values.
Here, she told the
model what data
target to forecast and
time series columns to use,
and provided a hint
regarding US-based holidays.
Finally, she passed in
the query of click streams
that looks back two years but
prunes out the last 30 days.
This model trains on
two years of data,
and then saves into the data
set for evaluation and serving.
She then used the
ML Forecast option
to forecast the next 30
days in the time series,
at a 90% confidence interval.
To verify the model estimates,
she selected the actuals
from the 30-day window.
From there, she could plot
the historical plus forecast
plus actual and the lower and
upper bound of the confidence
intervals.
This graph passes
a quick eye test.
You can see seasonality
changes over quarter,
and then surges
during the weekends.
Once we get into
the forecast, you
can see that the model is within
three of the four week windows,
and barely misses week 1, even
though it saw an upward trend.
With an end-to-end
workflow in place,
the data scientists can go
back into additional EDA
for outliers and errors, and
then persist these results back
to the warehouse and/or
share the model for serving.
With a top line model
in place, New Kicks
can move on to additional models
like per-store and per-product
based forecasting.
Problem solved.
In this demo, we showed you how
New Kicks efficiently extended
a BigQuery data warehouse to
create a demand forecasting
model by utilizing various
transformation patterns, flex
slots, federated queries, GIS,
and machine learning functions.
Check out these links to
learn more, and get started
with building your cloud native
data warehouse on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]